[MUSIC]
One of the first things you want to do is
to keep in mind that at the end of the day
you need to build something useful for
somebody.
So, one of the first tasks is to
figure out who is that somebody.
Who are you really serving?
And what is the job that
they're hiring you to do.
And looking at it from their
perspective will often yield
insights that are hidden from
the product owner or entrepreneur,
if we're purely looking at it from
the product-centric perspective.
[MUSIC]
A lot of it is about being at
the right place in the right time.
While you don't have control over timing,
you do have control over two variables,
the product and the market.
How you define the product, what goes
into their product, and as importantly,
what is left out of the product?
And the other variable is the market.
Who are you going sell it to?
Often times, it's much more
helpful to start with the market.
Yes, you have a set of hypotheses about
what your product is going to deliver
to whom.
It often costs you much less to start
testing your product value proposition to
a different market segment.
You're just talking to different people.
You're not investing any engineering
resources to revamp your product,
to build something different.
That's expensive, and that limits the
number of iterations you can go through.
But talking to different customers,
you can do that all day long.
So, start with a set of hypotheses and
go and test with your customers, and
iterate on the customer
side as rapidly as you can.
And it's not just about getting
customer feedback on your product or
your prototype.
It's actually even more important to
understand the world that your customers
live in because you often would find
that the original pain point that you
thought existed might not even
matter all that much to them.
But there are adjacent pain points to
that that are much more important,
much more valuable, and by going after
those you could extract a lot more value.
And since there are pain points
adjacent to the original pain
point you wanted to tackle, you might be
so lucky that your product doesn't need to
change all that much to solve a much
more valuable, more immediate, and
urgent pain point for the customer.
[MUSIC]
The framework consists of four
interfaces of the product: user,
application, data, and buyer.
The user interface is usually the one that
product designers tend to focus on first
because it drives
the whole user experience.
And that's usually important.
It should deserve a lot of attention.
You need to really understand, what is
the job that the user is trying to do in
order to design your product accordingly,
in a way that fits into their world.
So, that's the user interface part, and
most product designers have
that very well-understood.
The second interface is
application interface.
And what I mean by that, is how does
your product interact with other
products that exist in your end-user's
world or your customer's worlds?
What does your user do upstream or
downstream around your product?
What are they doing before they
engage with the product, and
what would they be doing afterwards?
Now, understanding this is important
because one, if you could better
integrate yourself with these other
products that are used by your users.
You'll have a much higher
chance of becoming embedded
in part of the standard routine,
the standard work flow,
which means you're more likely to
become part of the daily habits.
And that solves one of the biggest
problems in subscription businesses,
which is churn if your users have to
keep reminding themselves to come in and
use your product,
chances are you have much higher churn.
But if you become part of the daily habit,
or part of a standard work flow,
they just follow steps one, two, and
three, and step two is your product.
It gets used all the time.
You're going to have much lower churn.
A third benefit of thinking
through your application interface
is if you have identified upstream and
downstream applications that work
well together with your product.
Now, you could go to a customer and
offer a complete solution,
not just a point product which
delivers a lot more value.
And you could also leverage
these applications,
other application vendors as your partners
to bring you into their customer base.
The third interface is data interface,
and what I mean by that is,
think about what input data
you need from the user or
other sources, in order to do the job
that your users has hired you to do.
What is the format that
the data will be coming in?
What are the channels?
What are the best ways to collect that
data, and what is the minimum amount of
data you require your users to manually
enter in order to deliver value?
The more data you ask from a user the less
likely they are to do it actually,
because you're increasing the cost
of adopting your product.
But if you could minimize the manual
data input required of the user, and
try to automate the process of
delivering value as much as possible.
And sometimes by inferring conclusions or
making predictions based
on other data sets that you could
automatically ingest into your product.
Chances are you'll be able to
deliver a high level value
with a lower cognitive cost to your user.
So, that's the input side.
On the output side,
you need to think about how
the data is going to be consumed.
If the data you generate is a report,
for example, that is read by human
being you want to make sure
the visualizations are crisp and engaging.
If on the other hand, the data that you
generate are going to be consumed by
machines or other products downstream, you
might need to think about how best should
I format the data and through what
channel should I be delivering the data.
So, that I maximize the likelihood
of the data being consumed and
made valuable by a downstream product And
then the last interface,
buyer interface, refers to
the interface between the product and
buyer, which may not be the end user.
And this is often times the interface that
is most often neglected by
product designers because to
design a product that is easily consumed
by a buyer, or purchased by a buyer,
requires deep understanding of how
your buyer makes purchasing decisions.
And this set of activities are often
viewed as something owned by sales or
marketing, not by product and engineering.
But without understanding
how a buyer discovers and
purchases your product,
you miss out on the opportunity of
optimizing the design of your product
to be purchased as easily as possible.
I'll give you an example.
If an organization requires
a certain trial period for
a product before they will decide to buy.
You would want to design
a product in such a way
that the trial period could be self-served
by the customer or prospective, or
potential customer without requiring a lot
of pre-sales resources on your part.
Otherwise, it would be much more
costly for you to qualify a lead and
scale your revenue.
So, this is a simple example of how
understanding the buying process has
impact on your product design decisions.
[MUSIC]
What the most common trap
that entrepreneurs fall into,
is if you're getting
some level of traction,
you're seeing some level of growth,
but it's just not explosive.
And that's a hard zone to be in
because it's hard to give up.
You have customers.
You are seeing growth,
it's just not explosive growth.
But if you're not driving
explosive growth,
then it's hard to become a dominant
player in your industry.
So, that's probably the most
difficult zone to be in because
you are always being drawn to staying with
what is somewhat working in the market.
That what the entrepreneur needs
to do in that case is to look for
ways to get to that perfect
part of market fit, so
that your revenue would start
picking up exponentially.
It could be by pricing a product
differently, positioning differently, or
going after an adjacent market segment
without changing your product all
that much.
[MUSIC]